Mein Vornamn ist Jonas J.O.N.A.S.
Danke und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 19. Januar 1982.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,79 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 76 kg.
Und wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Es ist der Herr Schmitz.
Herr Fischer, was fügt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe jetzt schon seit ungefähr einer Woche Halsschmerzen auf der rechten Seite.
Ich habe immer wieder so Abgeschlagenheit.
Ich schwitze viel, ich habe Herzrasen.
Und das macht mir Sorgen.
Seit einer Woche?
Ja, ungefähr so acht Tagen.
Halsschmerzen?
Ja, hier Halsschmerzen da.
Wie treten diese Schmerzen auf langsam oder plötzlich?
Die sind eigentlich die ganze Zeit da.
Die werden mal schlechter, mal abgeschwächter, aber meist sind die ganze Zeit da.
Können Sie mir bitte beschreiben, wie sind diese Schmerzen?
Erdumpf oder drückenstechend?
Erdumpf, aber auch so ein bisschen stechend manchmal.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz,
oder von eins bis zu einer, wobei sie sehr leicht sind,
und sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Also fünf.
Haben Sie auch geschwollene Knoten bemerkt im Hals oder andere Körperregion?
Nein.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinauf?
Also ein bisschen, hier in Kiefer und im Ohrbereich, manchmal den gesamten Hals.
Haben Sie einen bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen?
Das wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen da oder gehen Sie auch wieder?
Die werden manchmal weniger, aber die sind eigentlich immer da.
Haben Sie so etwas für die Herrscher schon einmal?
Noch nie.
Sind diese Schmerzen im Verlauf lindert oder verstärkt?
Ich denke verstärkt.
Also das bleibt gleich, aber es geht nicht weg.
Ich habe früher schon mal Halsschmerzen gehabt,
aber die sind weggegangen, aber diese gehen nicht weg.
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Also wenn ich drauf zurück, tut es weh.
Ich brauche drücke.
Mit Drucken schlimmer?
Richtig.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden oder Schmerzen im andere Köpferregion?
Nein, mir macht das Herzrahmen auch ein bisschen Sorgen.
Haben Sie auch Burusschmerzen?
Schmerzen nicht, Burusschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Nur Herzrahmen?
Richtig.
Haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie Fabian Schweitz aus Brühe nachts oder tagsüber?
Beides.
Manchmal ist es mir auch ganz kalt.
Aber manchmal habe ich auch wieder ganz warm.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich denke schon, ja, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Aber ich denke schon.
Sie fühlen sich fieberig.
Richtig.
Aber Sie haben nicht gemessen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in der Starseite?
Ein bisschen weniger.
Aber ich kann gut essen.
Haben Sie ungewollt ab oder so genommen in letzter Zeit?
In den letzten acht Tagen nicht, vielleicht ein Kilo oder so, aber nicht besonders.
Vielleicht ein Zeit, aber nicht mehr.
In letzter Zeit?
Ja, aber ich denke nicht viel.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, wenn ich diese Herzrasen bekomme, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Wenn das Herzkopf da ist, dann habe ich Probleme.
Dann beide sind es.
Herr Fischer, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturrgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen weicheren Sturrgang.
Weichere?
Haben Sie Durchfalle oder nur weichere Sturrgang?
Nur weichere Sturrgang.
Herr Fischer, jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer vorgeschichte einige Fragen stellen.
Neiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen.
Nein, ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Noch nie.
Haben Sie regelmäßig oder geregentlich einige Medikamente?
Wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen ein.
Aber das ist nicht so oft.
Wie stark sind diese Ibuprofen?
400, glaube ich.
Haben Sie regelmäßig oder unverträglichen Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Herr Fischer, rauchen Sie?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich nehme keine Drohnen ein.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Bürokaufmann.
Ich habe keine Drohnen.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Bürokaufmann.
Ich habe keine Drohnen.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Bürokaufmann.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin beschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Mit wem wohnen Sie jetzt?
Nein, ich wohnen ein.
Und jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Gebt es irgendwer, wer ist der Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Meine beiden Eltern haben Bluthochdruck.
Ansonsten war mein Geschwister nicht übernussbekannt.
Ihr Geschwister sind gesund.
Gesund, ja.
Waren Sie im Letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Sind Sie gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19 geimpft?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Ich bin im Ausland.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen oder möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich bin ein bisschen besorgt.
Könnte das auch als Krebs sein?
Also, weil das nicht weggeht.
Herr Fischer, bitte machen Sie jetzt keine Sorgen.
Es ist gut, dass Sie ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun, das Sie ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Wir werden alle wichtige Untersuchungen machen.
Wir werden die richtige Diagnose stellen
und Ihnen helfen.
Bitte machen Sie sich jetzt keine Sorgen.
Muss es denn im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Vielleicht.
Es hängt die Ergebnisse der Untersuchungen ab.
Jetzt werde ich zuerst ihre Körperländer unterzugen und dann etwas Blut abnehmen und vielleicht gegebenenfalls eine ultra-schale Unterzuhung,
einblutend ist ein kann, je nachdem ergebnisse wir werden sprechen, die weitererrennt.
Jetzt würde ich Sie bitten noch einmal kurz im Vartezimmer Platz zu nehmen, wir rufen Sie Ihnen wenn ihr gelb in der
auf und mit der Untersuchung anzufangen.
Alles klar. Vielen Dank. Ich warte noch.
Dankeschön. Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Knot und Schwellen in Ihrem Halsbereich bemerkt?
Hab ich beantwortet, nein.
Hatte Sie vor Kurzem erklärt, mit einer Frage?
Ja, ich war ungefähr zwei Wochen in der Kälte.
Ich war auch beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Er hatte mir noch mal eine Altebiolikum aufgeschrieben.
Welche Antibiotika?
Ich hatte da Amoklar bekommen.
Amoksoziolinklavolansäure, ich glaube ich.
Ich habe keinen Hausfall.
Also wenn ich Herzrasen habe,
dann zittern so ein bisschen meine Hände, das stimmt.
Jetzt ist nicht so dramatisch, aber nur wenn ich Herzrasen habe.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Luftnot habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, keine Fragen.
Ja, gar. Ich sehe nicht.
Warum? Er fragt Kollegen.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ein Stress habe ich auch nicht.
Schluckgeschwerden, nicht wirklich, nein.
Ich kann gut essen, gut trinken.
Nein, ich habe keine Frage.
Es war einmal gesund.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ja.
Senabitation.
ammenRaten.
저.
Her Yunas Fischer,
2.40 Jahre alt.
Aufgrund seit ungefähr acht Tagen bestehender Halsschmerzen im rechten Bereich begleitet der Patient über
die Möglichkeit Fatigue und Hyperhydrosis und Hyperhydrosis und
Wir haben auch 3-Mord in den Handen.
Was haben wir?
3-Mord in den Handen.
3-Mord?
Ja, 3-Mord.
4-Mord.
Verneint wurden die Fragen nach Gechwolle, die Noten, Brustschmerzen und Luftnoten.
Die Schmerzen in der Stahl wurden mit 5 von 10 auf der Schmerzskale bewertet.
Die Schmerzen schüttere in die Mandibule und manmal gezammte Hals aus.
Die Schmerzen sind weniger.
Der Patient fühlt sich fibrig, aber die Temperatur nicht gemessen.
Die vegetative Anamnese seit einigen Aufwärtskarten in Appetenz 1-2 kg Gewichtsverlust in letzten 8 Tagen
in Form von Ein- und Durchlafsstörungen.
Sie haben kein Problem mit dem Sturrgang oder Beinwassern.
Nur er sagt, dass er weiter stülhaben, aber nicht durfallen.
Der Patient hat vor 2 Wochen eine Erkartung mit Antibiotikum,
aber sie sind klar, dass sie behandelt wurden.
Keine Vorerkrankungen und keine Voroperationen.
Er nehme gelegentlich gegen Kopfschmerzen Ibuprofen 400 mg.
Er habe keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit.
Er arbeitet als Bruchaufmann, geschieht und habe keine Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese der Vater und die Mutter hatte Hb-Arteriellehypertone.
Der Patient rauchend nicht, trinkt selten Alkohol
und er ist gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19 geimpft.
Okay.
Herr Kollege, könnt ihr Sie bitte zusammen passen?
Nur hauptbechverden und begleitbechverden?
Der Patient beklagt über Halsschmerzen,
insbesondere rechtzeitig mit Ausstrahlung in den Bereich der Mandibular
und auch aurikulär.
Es war auch berichtet über Tachikadephasen,
welche ihm auch Schlafstörungen bereiten.
Außerdem fühle er sich fieberig.
Der Appetit wäre gut.
Er habe wahrscheinlich gerne auch 1-2 kg Angewicht verloren.
Er beschreibt, er habe eine Erkältung gehabt,
welche vor zwei Wochen mit einem Antibiotikum am Moxiklar behandelt wurde.
Er habe keine Vorerkrankungen,
nehme keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein,
außer ab und an bei Kopfschmerzen über Profäen 400 mg.
Er ist beschieden, ist allein lebend, hat keine Kinder.
Die Eltern haben keine relevanten Vorerkrankungen,
bis auf Bluthochbruch.
Die Geschwister seien alle gesund.
Von Beruf her sei er Bürokaufmann, Auslandsaufenthalter
und Voroperationen werden verneint.
Hobbys haben er keine, wurden nicht gefragt.
Danke, Shannon, danke.
Bitte schön, Senor.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich den Verdacht auf
Postinfektion, Subacut, Trioditis.
Und als differenzial Diagnosen,
habe ich die Diagnose,
die Leinfadenitis und die Schutterung,
die Nodeuse in Betracht.
Wegen des Verdacht auf eine Postinfektion,
die Subacut, Trioditis,
werde ich zuerst der Patientkörperlihe untersuchen.
Ich habe dabei besonders auf die Knoten im Hals
und ob es Strom im Hals gibt.
Dann lege ich einen Venösenfgang und nehme gleichzeitig Blut ab.
Aus dem Blut möchte ich ein kleines Blutbild,
TRP, BSG, TSH, Preis T3 und T4.
Außerdem möchte ich eine, oder mache ich,
eine Ultraschall der Schilddrüse.
Was sehen Sie da? Was können Sie da sehen?
Ich kann sehr größerte Tiroide
in der Knoten im Schilddrüse sehen.
Was ist typisch?
Was kann man da sehen?
Muss nicht unbedingt sein, kann sein, richtig?
Man sieht oft Echo-Arme, Areale,
wie eine Landkarte.
Landkarten, förmige Strukturen kann man sehen.
Echo-Arme ist sehr typisch für eine supergute Tiroide.
Das ist typisch, das ist fast schon beweisend.
Aber alles andere war richtig, was Sie gesagt haben.
Ich denke auch, dass es eine supergute Tiroide sein könnte.
Man muss dennoch die Differenzialdiagnosen
mit bedenken.
Man muss gucken, es kann auch eine einfache Consilitis sein.
An trotzdem Seite, wenn das Antibiotikum nicht angeschlagen hat,
dass eine einseitige Seitenstrange an Gener sein könnte.
Zum Beispiel an Gener Ponsilaris.
Es kann sein, dass es ein Abzest ist.
Man muss dann denken, man muss natürlich auch
eine bösartige Erkrankung, wie zum Beispiel,
wie Sie richtig gesagt haben, Lymphom, Lymphadenitis,
an all die Sachen mitdenken.
Richtig.
Was machen Sie als Therapie?
Machen Sie irgendwas?
Sie gehen wieder nach Hause, alles wird gut.
Nein, zur Weite dann auch klar.
Und möchte ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und wegen, wenn sich der Verdacht auf eine Tiroiditis bestätigt,
führe ich die folgende Massnahmen durch
und nicht die Tiroide alle an die Promethoika.
Promethoika?
Was noch?
Er nimmt dir schon manchmal Ibuprofen ein, aber es kann nicht zurück.
Er hat ja gesagt, er nennt manchmal bei Kopfschmerzen
und sobald Ibuprofen erneut, das wird anscheinend nicht so gut.
Was kann man dann noch machen?
Methamysol?
Nein, lieber nicht.
Kann man machen, aber ich glaube, das bringt nicht viel.
Man kann die Ibuprofentherapie erhöhen auf 600, 800
oder man gibt Diplofenac, kann man auch geben.
Aber was kann man noch geben bei einer super guten Tiroiditis?
Corticoide.
Leucocorticoide.
Kann man machen, wenn die Symptomatik sehr ausgeprägt ist,
wichtig sind hier, um die Entzündung zu hemmen,
sollte man tatsächlich dann Cortison geben,
auch für mehrere Wochen in ausschleichtender Sosierung.
Das ist ja eine selbstheilende,
meist selbstheilende Erkrankung, sich selbst limitiert,
nur wenn die Symptomobil bei diesen Patienten sehr ausgeprägt sind
und Lebensqualität einschränkend sind,
dann sollte man auf jeden Fall NSR oder Leucocorticoide einsetzen.
Und man sollte natürlich auch alle drei bis vier Wochen einmal
die schilddrüsen Hormone kontrollieren.
Wenn er jetzt Herzrasen hat,
hat er dann eher eine Hypothyriose oder Hyperthyriose?
Hyperthyriose.
Genau, das ist ja meistens so,
dass man bei einer Tiroiditis, de Quavon, eine Hyperthyriose hat
und dann leicht in einer Unterfunktion
und vielleicht einhergehen kann,
sogar im Verlauf,
und dann normalisiert das sich wie eine Euthyriose.
Ja, ich denke, das ist richtig.
Man muss die Patienten nicht stationär behalten,
wenn man weiß, dass er das hat.
Wenn man sagt, okay, ich habe jetzt Ultraschall gemacht
und die Werte sind nicht so extrem,
dann kann man diesen Patienten auch nach Hause entlassen,
theoretisch gesehen.
Es sei denn, er hat eine tyriotoxische Krise,
aber das ist jetzt nicht so oft eigentlich.
Wir haben meistens ein erniedrigtes TSH,
ein erhöhtes FD4, FD3,
und wenn man die Therapie mit NSR
und Glucocortico beginnt
oder auch mit Beta-Blockern, wie Sie gesagt haben,
Propranolol zum Beispiel,
kann man geben,
dass das sich dann wieder normalisiert.
Es dauert ein, zwei Wochen,
aber manchmal, also manchmal,
in der Regel ist es nach drei, vier, fünf Monaten,
ist das dann ausgeschlichen, ist alles wieder gut.
Aber es kann wieder auftreten bei den Patienten.
Das muss man den Patienten sagen.
Wenn wir den Patienten aufruhen für andere Kontrolle?
Also das kann der Hausarzt auch machen,
das müssen Sie nicht machen.
Survival?
Für die Kontrolle der Schilddrüsenwerte.
Zwei, drei Wochen auf jeden Fall.
Man sagt vier Wochen,
aber ich mache das meistens früher.
Ob ich dann,
wann weiß ich, ob es besser ist,
wenn es nicht besser ist.
Ob die Therapie ansteckt oder nicht ansteckt.
Eine Kollegin hat geschrieben,
eine Tyrostatikgabe ist kontraindesiert.
Moment, Moment.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, ein Moment.
Eine Tyrostatikgabe ist kontraindesiert.
Bei Hypothriöse.
Richtig, muss man auch nicht machen.
Man muss sich nur beobachten.
Wenn er zum Beispiel eine Herzfrequenz von 130 hat,
dann sollte man die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Aber wenn er jetzt nur 100 hat oder 95 hat und Herzrasen hat,
dann muss man den Patienten nicht stationär aufnehmen.
Bei Hypothriöse ist es kontraindesiert.
Aber die Hypothriöse ist kontraindesiert.
Alle eine Tyrostatikgabe,
bei der Hypothriöse ist auch kontraindesiert.
Ob das Kontraindesiert ist weiß nicht,
aber man gibt das normalerweise nicht.
Man macht das normalerweise nicht.
Bei jeder Tyrostatikgabe, natürlich.
Ich hatte vorher einen Mann, das ist immer nicht.
Sind die Grafen?
Die Grafen muss man nicht unbedingt machen.
Dann auch?
Man kann das machen, aber meistens ist das selbst Heilung.
Man muss das nicht machen.
Man kann das machen, aber man muss nicht machen.
Wenn die Schilddrüsenwerte nicht besser sind,
dann muss man keine Zitrage machen.
Bei der Differenz der Diagnose
kann es sein, bei der FSB,
man kann es sagen.
Man muss es denken,
aber es ist auch Fieber.
Stimmt, ich habe nicht dran gedacht.
Aber bei Endocarditis hat man keine Schmerzen.
Herr Müssüdam,
kann man eine Erker-Tung machen?
Vielleicht, natürlich.
Kann man eine долгоer Erker-Tung machen?
Wenn der
Ich denke, da denkt man nicht immer dran. Man kommt nicht immer auf diese Erkrankung.
Sehr gut gemacht.